hi i'm leslie mann and i'm john
happentown welcome to the wired auto
complete interview
are we supposed to be bantery all the
time
because we don't really banter like this
no you ignore me and i ignore you
what does judd apatow
do that's an existential question right
there that's like a buddhist saying
that's like what is a hand what
what is the sound of one hand clapping
what does judd apatow do you know what
this should say
what should judd epitome do
what did judd apatow write
[Laughter]
you don't know by now
yeah uh what did i write your favorite
uh films
of all time
the ones that you like best the ones
that you think are better than all the
others
okay what
movies has judd apatow
acted in
i was in the the the movie about the
room where i played [ __ ] producer
what although in the credits it said
judd apatow as himself
didn't you play the elephant in the the
that one the zookeeper i was the
elephant in the zoo keeper you were very
proud of that it was a voiceover
performance really were you in um an
anchorman i smelled uh something that
stunk in anchorman didn't you do jay
leno or something i did an impression of
jay leno on an episode of the critic and
on the ben stiller show you just named
all five of my acting credits i wasn't
good in any of them what movies has judd
apatow directed
okay
i can't i can't just put a graphic up
right here in front of me
it's weird to make people like list
their credits i get that all the time
people come up to me and say oh my gosh
hey i love you
what were you in
and then i say
well um and i list what i've been been
in and they're like no
no
ha-ha
and then i just stand there like like an
idiot trying to remind them what they
know me from
okay what does judd apatow think of
euphoria i love euphoria it left me in a
puddle yeah i cried so hard it was so
good so amazing this season i enjoy moat
apatow's work
i feel like when i watch the show i
think am i supposed to direct like that
like it looks good really good and
there's like angles and the camera moves
i don't know how to do any of that
so i both i love it and then i'm like
quietly jealous and ashamed of myself
okay what does jed apatow look like
not like this all the time no
just imagine not showering add that to
this
and not dressing up
and
not taking care of myself in a way that
is that's the version i get yeah
you're the lucky one
what does leslie man
play in playing playing does that mean
like what you know what movies you're in
i think that's what that means
who calls it play some some people say
that some people say what what do you
play no one's ever said that what are
you playing
america's grammar is crazy what was
leslie mann's first movie
well i think my first movie was the one
where i where i had the really short
haircut um
okay i can't remember but the one i do
remember i played a prostitute on
it with bruce willis and you double
crossed him and i double crossed him and
he murdered me last man standing bruce
willis like beating you up because you
like ratted him out yeah it's actually
really good walter hill yeah warriors
coming in
i don't know what my natural hair color
is what is leslie man's natural hair
color it could be anything at this point
we don't know what's underneath there we
haven't looked in decades but you always
want me to dye my hair remember when you
dyed my hair
so during lockdown judd dyed my hair i
said
i need my roots done and she sent me
stuff stupidly thinking that i would be
able to figure out how to use it i
didn't i asked you to like put it on the
back part that i couldn't see
and he like put way too much and so this
whole area from here back was like
bright orange not an ugly orange it was
terrible it was like a big chunk of
orange
and i had to keep that for a long time
until it grew out what is leslie mann's
daughter's name i have two daughters
maud apatow is 24 and iris apatow is 19.
we kind of started talking about baby
names and my favorite movie is harold
and mod
my favorite tv show is mod and i said
what if her name is maude and we kind of
laughed about it and then it just stuck
and we just called her mod
for
my whole pregnancy and then she couldn't
be any anyone else she was just mod and
then iris we didn't have a name up until
the very end
and i was taking a nap one day because i
was huge and it was hot and i was
miserable and i fell asleep
and
and in my dream somebody whispered or
somebody whispered in my ear iris yeah
and i woke me up and i ran downstairs
and i said judd her name's iris and that
was it
that was me whispering
what is leslie mann
like in
real
life delightful
she's just like this all day
right pretty much yeah this isn't like a
character she's doing right now i'm in a
better mood right now than i normally am
but this is real life isn't it i think
are we in real life is judd apatow from
michigan no
long island
are judd apatow and adam sandler friends
they are very good friends is judd
apatow in anchorman
i am an anchorman i think i say that
something smells like
a
diaper filled with hot dog farts
are jen apatow and leslie mann still
married nope
nope
we're holding that back we're just
promoting the movie almost 25 years 25
years in june
isn't that crazy can you believe that
everyone got divorced in all of
hollywood except us
we're the last survivors
our jed
we are friends and i'm aging better than
him
you know it's true
his deal with the devil is working out
so well
is paul read married to leslie mann in
another reality
in another reality
are lazy man and cameron diaz friends
yes
i love i love love love her are leslie
manns daughters in this is 40. yes those
are my daughters mod and iris
and we hired them because
we don't like other people's children
and and judd tricked them into or
figured out a way to pay them very
little and then keep it for myself yeah
i both screwed them and stole from them
are leslie mann and catherine heigl
friends yes how come no one wants to
know who i'm friends with is leslie mann
and big daddy i am big daddy i play the
hooters girl as the hooters girl i had
um these breast
pads
something those were fake
i still have them i asked to keep them
after the movie and every year i have to
like care for them by taking them out of
these little plastic bags and putting um
baby powder on them to keep them from
disintegrating or something so
over the years like every year i
yeah maybe halloween but anyway i still
have them
it's so weird you asked it's disgusting
that you asked
chad avatar kanye west super bowl
um
yeah
john apatow king of seven these aren't
really questions you want to know
something about it they're just being
lazy yeah i do that and google guess is
right but when we google things it's
different we'll google like cats if they
could would they murder you
you know that's what our googles are
yeah cats do they really like you cats
are they only your friends mean when
they butt heads with you ours are mainly
cat searches cats if they sleep on the
pillow next to you will you get pink eye
yeah that's this is what we search
everything research is related to cats
yeah
they don't give you pink eye by the way
uh judd apatow mets pitch
that's that means people are looking at
my bad first pitch
and i don't think that's cool okay i did
the best i could i hadn't thrown a ball
in about 15 years and no i didn't meet i
did it didn't make it to the plate but
it went straight towards the plate and
so that's not that bad that look on your
face the look that you have when you're
doing the pitch which is like
like do that look
no but it's more like scared well
there's 50.
that's the look on his face every time
he takes a bite of soup he'll if it's
hot it might be hot i'm scared to fill
his spoon he gets the biggest spoon and
then he goes
and he can't not do it
he can't not make that face
and it's so good i can't watch him eat
i'm gonna eat that
i'm gonna pretend i'm eating soup he's
gonna
does leslie man
have a middle name yes it's jean
and it's a family name for like yeah
janet and jean janet leslie man beverly
hills chihuahua i was in that movie but
i don't think that i would had credit in
it or something well those secrets out
you were a dog in that movie i was i was
in that movie what dog were you some
kind of like shopping dog like a little
time are they all shopping dogs i can't
remember leslie man yelling at kid that
that's this is 40. yeah ryan lee ryan
lee he's so funny i did yell at him
it was satisfying and we've always
wanted to do that
you always wanted to tell off that
parent all parent knows what we're
talking about yeah and when some kids
mean to your kid you want to curse them
out you want to curse them out and you
did that for america and the world
leslie mann australian accent i'm
terrible with accents terrible i've
worked really hard at trying to learn
this australian accent and
this is 40. no funny people
and with eric banner and he sat with me
for hours trying to teach me and i just
couldn't get it can you still do an
australian accent bring me my didgeridoo
i want to play it while i eat this
vegemite sandwich bring me my didgeridoo
this limits the career in such a big way
you could have played all of the
australian people in australia wait
there's one there's there's like a thing
that our kids say all the time with that
australian accent
how to be single leslie man i was in a
movie how to be single i watched part of
it the other day and it's very good
and uh it was jake lacy was your love
interest yeah jacob and you guys are
adorable together but then we watch
white lotus and he's like a dick he said
[ __ ] yeah what a great actor because
he was so charming with you and then so
terrible to the other people i guess
that's good acting what is he like in
real life adorable yeah we don't know i
know i worked with one of the girls
this has been auto complete with leslie
mann and judd apatow i learned that like
when people google my name they're not
looking for sexy pics of me where on the
internet are sexy pics of judd ever do a
porno what website is it on their
interest in me is limited which is good
you don't really want people googling
you that much you want people not
googling you
yeah
you